please put your hands together pumping
bronzer and director of baby driver mr.
s you're right
hello everybody
tonight TIFF and I are going on a date
we're going to be watching the movie I'm
going to be having dinner later tonight
it's our favorite pastime actually our
favorite kind of date and we thought
we'd take a new segment on our channel
we've decided to call it a new segment
movies and foodie so I'm really looking
forward to this new segment because we
do this every single weekend so Isaac
spends his weekends at his dad's place
and so we kind of take advantage of that
free time to have our own little date on
the weekend and we thought like we
should be making videos about this
really bringing you guys along to join
us well we get to go see every single
movie that comes out Casey's like you
guys know he's like a movie fanatic
she's always constantly trying to watch
the newest movies everything we get in a
head like a specific thing we can't just
rent movie or like stream Mel or
anything happen go into the theater sit
down in the theater and actually
experience moving buy a truck you win so
that every place that home theaters just
don't do it for me yep so that's the
reason why we must come to the movie
theaters every single weekend and after
that we always go find a new place to
eat and so we thought you know what this
would be a perfect segment on our
channel we get to review the movie we
just watched and get to review the
restaurant that we're eating yet so
we're about to go watch baby driver some
what is it you do
I'm a driver Oh like a chauffeur
anyone I'd know what is your name
favorite your name's baby baby why baby
river drivers are so hype about this
movie why there is one director that has
this very peculiar style that I'm a
really really really big fan of in this
name is Edgar Wright but the best part
about this screening is actually the
Edgar Wright will be here to do a QA
after the film and I'm so excited
Stan speak he had an accident when he
was a kid still has a hum in the drum
plays music to drown it out and that's
what makes him the best baby driver is
the action comedy musical directed by
Edgar Wright and starring Ansel Elgort
early change Lisa Gonzales Jon Hamm
James Boggs tennis basics about a
getaway driver who has the conscience
and does one thing that says like no
more you know we don't talk and you're
trying to get out but it's all in love
no I don't think I need to give you this
regional what happens when you say no
how I can break your legs until everyone
you love because you already know that
done yeah it's it's really there's a
movement your kitchen book pays off you
got really sick driving skills let's
watch it
what you think in the movie oh my gosh
movie was freaking awesome it was so
cool I loved how the entire movie well a
good chunk of the movie was edited to
match the beats of the music and they
just like really so filled a lot of like
that oh seediness and me where I'm like
oh like it just I just can't put it into
words it was a really cool movie and I
love the color of it too the art
direction was really dope I really loved
how they created like the whole world it
was almost like a little cartoony event
editor right if he wasn't in art or
before he's really becoming an art or
now because every horse and on tour is
basically a term you to describe certain
directors like Quentin Tarantino Wes
Anderson just means that these directors
have a very specific flavor it's very
specific vision for the movies the movie
was phenomenal from the trailers I
thought the way they edited some action
scenes to the music was really cool I
then realized how much of that was
actually in the movie in full movies
like that the whole movie is
choreographed and orchestrated around
the song and the song played a huge role
I thought guardians of the galaxy was
heavily inspired by the music but baby
driver took music to a whole nother
level and how they incorporated into the
film and it was just kind of
mind-blowing like watching a one time
does not do it justice so what we're
going to go watch it again seeing as
there was a diner implemented in the
movie a lot we're going to go to a diner
to go I love diner food yeah we're going
to melt
let's go so we're now at Mel's Diner
here in Hollywood interesting thing
though a couple years ago went to the
comedy store could love it we had
invited us JK films to go see him
perform doing a stand-up so after that
show she brought us to Mills so we
actually had dinner with him designer so
it's pretty cool that we're back now so
we got some chili cheese fries and I
ordered the classic Mel burger and you
got bacon eggs I can't decide every time
I come to a diner I can never decide on
what to eat is the negative so dude you
know they're like so many options at a
diner I just all I didn't bracket I just
felt like circled and highlighted in my
first colors on the menu 24 sirloin
steaks all right make it is tonight fun
decision-making I love how we both have
a menu we're like right
[Music]
we are the burner
guard the hare difficult Patrick burger
but I did ask for communion prayer sign
medium
[Music]
in the movie oh good I mean I get that
soundtrack every time we watch a movie
and really often on track we always go
to Spotify like a lot of the land when
we watch that he listened a lot land for
like a good like month Isaac's still
listening to the soundtrack every time
it takes a shower actually don't you
don't have the phones over in that
sounds are mmm you're right sounded like
the new Tarantino half Tarantino and
Holly's movie he features a lot of music
by a very classic music and at the same
time you also find songs or a classic
that most people haven't really heard of
like lean on Mason underground
old school talk yeah and Edgar Wright is
exactly the same thing with this like he
found a lot of music I've never ever
heard of good guardian James Gunn or he
mentioned James Gunn in the Q&A and he's
like good friends with James Gunn who
directs the arms of galaxies and he was
saying that through the end they were
messaging back and forth about the kind
of music they were using in their film
so that they wouldn't duplicate it and
they wouldn't you know how it seems
music's so it was funny because
everything like you have a parent wife
your virginity said no because that you
have a Fleetwood Mac you know like that
a resource establishment I mean with the
Katie about it neither of us were spaces
so there'd be that thing like film it
not literally like I still think saying
like hocus-pocus would make a great song
connection to you never tell anybody
about like an artist like mentality they
want to give too much away about each
other's movie
that's not how is interesting about the
movie was the quality of the stunt you
know a movie that features a lot of
driving in fashion seriously after
watching fat superiors they never go
home thinking and then those are scenes
are amazing
I think it's because that is very 30g
driven now and water does not work isn't
realistic anymore I know so I don't know
a lot of action movies is that they
really want to make you feel like you're
there guess you go Daisy so the camera
keeps shaking another doing it on
purpose so they want to show you the
action through the camera work but in
this movie I didn't see that a lot they
actually just let the scene play through
and then you can feel the action through
that a lot of wide shot which a lot of
action movies don't do anymore
yeah but for all its glory in the
technical world one thing about the
movie I didn't really like with your
writing that's up the writing with a bid
we're looking at easy mm-hmm very cliche
the flick the storyline that we've all
seen before there might be a drive
really a guy that doesn't talk a whole
lot of baby in this movie he doesn't
talk a whole lot it reminded me of Ryan
Gosling's performance and drive and then
I happens to be a getaway driver there's
almost the same thing some people evolve
came before branding that's the beauty
of Edgar Wright did you look at all
Edgar Wright movies he basically does
parodies but if carry that's been done
very sophisticated there's real
properity in room for comedy but at the
same time he leaves a lot of room for
dramas I mean that's the genius of
you're right where he make sophisticated
parody mashanda that that ago with the
literary parroting every single zombie
movie out there we wouldn't go slap
Nicki where it was like scary movie
Randolph Jeremy Konner dead is like
miles beyond during movie I think
there's a moment to found and then where
you pick a character seriously for clip
ii where things really go fast for the
characters you know he's kind
so I feel what they're feeling and you
know we're a scary movie when things
evaporated characters are still laughing
at you I think that's a huge difference
between Edgar Wright sound laughing this
until the Eifel came out then people
could stop sound tracking their life
when you could really kind of stop
you know trying to plan out your mood by
what you elicited to action to making
endless plain the Q&A door right was
saying that when he first came up with
this idea it was like 23 years ago he
had the idea of the fact that people can
set their own soundtrack to their lives
and so back then there was no iPod right
Edgar was that players and stuff like
that once the iPod actually came out in
2001 as in heroes that I always called
in perfectly with my idea of movie of
having somebody have like an entire
soundtrack to their lives and we've all
been there we have all played near they
can run and meet with well the music
especially when I'm driving to something
like those you know music you know why's
them are yeah yeah I cut up Hawaii okay
let's let this very manly of you but
it's definitely hard it's like I do I
really need to get their facts right now
yes I think you're there you come every
day
I don't wanna be that's something you
don't do that I'm telling you do your
you through live in a movie because it's
a movie thing to do it is it is you have
a soundtrack I don't know if I was sound
but I guess I do play songs become a
goon I like to listen to a lot of like
still kind of new Vegas asleep
I'm driving traffic in LA is really
stressful so I try not to play like
accessible kind of usually portishead
thank you doing know how forty times are
like the cure of the album's integration
that's like probably the soundtrack of
my life what would you rate I would give
it a four and a half stars only reason
why they don't get the other half
because of their writing like writing
really good I was playing a lot of good
TV I would give it it hi oh you can see
by it's not like oh you're right
yes I recommend it Peter says you want
to be locked into the theater a stone
and no distraction oh we have a good
crowd you're going on or helpless or
whatever
we're like louder taking them hairs on
your socks I know I was sitting like
this couple where they were just like
really loud they were talking a lot more
even if space is your chair so I was
right next to it looks like I can enjoy
this movie always yeah make sure it fell
under like before I hear you okay guys
the definition of is more you never know
I come check out my liner but what is
how much can I think of this news
segments
movies and beauty and let us know what
we'll do in select next and where we
should go eat eggs thanks for watching
and are you rocking tonight okay okay
everybody one
Topshop Nordstrom's not my outfit
looking hot looking section how do you
know where you were you got something
from you actually remember those things
yeah
top man don't know these Panther bro
don't know everything
yeah I don't know no I I don't know I
don't know anything I came oh man I buy
it I forget the price I forget words
from a specific guy I am very very much
so but yeah I know
you guys are always asking me worried
about myself skills okay I thought in
this video might as well the to stuff
worth what everything
[Music]